та rhino то вікторія студентки донецького
національного університету обживаються
орендованій квартирі у провини ті й звали
за ми ваніно розлучається в жирик
спочатку випливав із донецька при панелі
навчання подали вигляд б лиходіїв путін
шкідливих містечок про донецьку та область
куди Левит обставивши то дивана члени
знала що зможе продовжити і порушуючи
шкідливому ващі я спочатку поїхав аваль я
спочатку поїхав пеклі львів потім будинку
кулаєва вона все-таки кула і відразу мило
чуді можна повернутися сюди вийшов я
повернулася і масажуєш зв'язковий попит
заздрість 11 головних корпусі фуду не течуть
рибу здивували
депо правах на б місяць адже part держава
частин кого компенсуючи vortice оренди то
комунальні платежі
молодша зарплатня нюта стипендії з
закупівля та необхідне володіння до
допомагають міжнародні фонди та спонсори
відгуку держава нацик вже темний травень
попроси у студента хіміки та фізики
диявол зник доля не лабораторії, а на
факультеті журналістики нова
апаратура те, що в нас була там і то
що було там те база нашу повний син
сестри mavala
the deck за роз'єм усі чоловіки вас this
form його табель що приватну перспективно
то актуального жертва
база у team головна проблема завищується
всі студенти так само як і вокалу дачі
закриваючи ректор заміж і не ви найму то
житло а ви на буде тримаючи почали його
право ви знаєте
м'язи просто один чоловік помістився
облоги
я висловив сьогодні c700 тереке викладок
встигай hipster
велика армія студентів з сили колектив
угурту рідкий маленьку і знайти для
університету дізнаєшся нині більше тисячі
сильних місць
то дід під риба ще на меншу piatra
беша донецьку національний університет
став першим вищим, що у хвали у рішенні
про евакуацію
до провини за даними мін усвяти в Донецьку
та луганську областях проти ламаєш 200
вишивки технікумі криві ви знаєте
реальність вище з чуддю вийшов і сів так
званих днр і лнр і rhino the victorian та
хоче уду знайти тут під мирним небом
вінниці іван і по-новому стала тягнуло tt
що підірвали мати чоловіка весь 4